I'm Jerry Willis I'm Steve Doocy i'm
shannon bream and this is the fox news
rundown
[Music]
Wednesday April 15 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal states are talking
about reopening their economies to a
certain extent but it's far from clear
when I think the best approach is going
to be focusing on the table not on the
date and seven criteria here gradually
and safely reopening I'm Dave Anthony
since most of us are stuck at home
airports are like ghost towns planes are
nearly empty when airlines are losing a
hundred million dollars a day so either
we get up out of our caves and start to
bring the economy back even wave goodbye
to this airline industry and I'm Leslie
Marshall I've got the final word on the
Fox News rundown
[Music]
this week the governors of New York New
Jersey Connecticut Pennsylvania Rhode
Island and Delaware said they would work
together on how to reopen their shops
and schools California's governor said
working with Washington and Oregon they
would look at their own plans to reopen
and on Tuesday governor Gavin Newsom
said it wasn't going to be based around
dates there's no light switch here I
would argue it's more like a dimmer he
said a number of key things need to
happen first the most important
framework is our capacity to expand our
testing to appropriately address the
tracing and tracking of individuals the
isolation and the quarantine we'd also
need to have enough therapeutic drugs on
hand and hospitals would have to assure
health officials that they had enough
personal protective gear and ventilators
in case there were to be a surge but
Newsom said even when we do go back to
some kind of life where a business and
restaurants are open your waiter may be
wearing a mask and gloves dinner where
the menu is disposable where the tables
half of the tables in that restaurant no
longer appear where your temperature is
checked before you walk in to the
establishment these are likely scenarios
he said schools may rethink how they
hold classes how students eat in
cafeterias and participate in sports
many of us may end up wearing face
coverings for a while and governor
Newsom says all of this really may be
necessary until there's a vaccine the
thing is there's no when when is this
over and that's frustrating I think we
need to focus not so much on the when to
reopen but on the what we all need to do
so that when we do reopen we can do so
as soon and as safely as possible dr.
Thomas Frieden is the CEO of resolve to
save lives and he's also the former
director of the CDC and there are things
we can do to make it more likely that as
we reopen we mimic the kind of second
way that we may face get a little bit
more specific with me what in your mind
does that look like is that hey let's
not tie this to a date but let's all
wear
and do 6 feet of social distancing until
like the end of summer I think we have
to look at a few different things one of
them is how extensively is the virus
spreading in each community and I do
think we need to handle this differently
in different communities recognizing at
the same time that we're all so
connected and people travel so there is
a real need for there to be a national
consistency in the approach that's taken
but looking at how much the virus is
spreading how safe we can keep our
health care workers and how effectively
our public health system can fax the
virus in Occident to me is the key
concept four corners of a box widespread
testing respective isolation complete
contact tracing and quarantine of
contacts if you can do those four things
well you can keep the virus in the box
instead of keeping the rest of us in the
box
it sounds like China makes the case that
they put this virus in a box but but but
there's still a lot of skepticism about
their initial numbers where are you on
believing China and their numbers and
whether or not they successfully
eventually put the virus in a box there
whatever you believe about their initial
response and their public statements
there is one thing that we really need
to learn from China which is they had
essentially controlled this and not
everything they've done will be
applicable here in the US but if we
don't learn that lesson we will fail any
controlling doctor as you know we're now
doing serological testing in some areas
of the country including here in
California that's the blood draw to see
if people have antibodies developed to
this virus there's this belief in
California for example that we all have
it already and that's why our count is
lower than some other places like New
York's I'm doubtful I'm not a scientist
but I'm doubtful of this because if that
were the case wouldn't we have also had
so many more deaths from some
unexplained pneumonia type illness in
January and February if we were all
walking around with this
virus in the winter yes you're exactly
right I think one of the things that
we're learning is that certain people
are much less likely to get severely ill
children are less likely to get severely
ill women appear to be less likely to be
severe little than men with this virus
although still it can be quite deadly
for anyone who is infected when we think
about serology testing or a blood test
to see if we have antibodies there's
still a lot we don't know we don't know
what the portion of people have been
infected yet but those tests will help
us we don't know whether antibodies will
protect against a future infection and
if so for how long we're hopeful the
antibodies are protected but those
studies haven't been done yet and our
best estimates based on the epidemiology
are that a very low proportion of the
country has been infected so far and
that means that the virus essentially
has an open field hood on that if we're
not careful when we come out again we
could keep massive spread I want to talk
about moving forward briefly in terms of
roles and responsibilities because the
president says the federal government is
a backup for the states on April 12th he
tweeted that governor's need to gear up
with more face masks and get your
state's testing programs perfected
should states have a more robust role in
preparing themselves for disasters and
emergencies or did they already like you
you ran the CDC for years what is the
role of States and does it need to shift
now moving forward under the US
Constitution health is primarily a state
affair and yet the federal government
has certain essential functions of
setting guidelines setting criteria
promoting consistency in approaches
across areas this is something that's
really quite important because what
we're going to see going forward I'm
afraid is that some parts of the country
in some parts of the world that don't do
a good job controlling this are going to
see the places that have control that
say hey we don't want you coming here or
if you come here
we need you to quarantine for 14 days
when you first come here that's
something that's almost inconceivable to
see that implement in the US and yet if
you look around the world more and more
countries are doing something like that
if they've gone through immense effort
to control kovat in their country and
then they see people coming in and
spreading it or even people from one
part of the country coming into a mother
part of the country and spreading it
it's going to be a problem so we're all
in this together we need the federal
government to set clear guidance and we
need the state cities and localities to
lead the local implementation if that
guy people seem dr. Hebert focused on
the president's desire to open the
country back up and you know whenever he
wants to I know it's it's fluid it
changes it's not like one specific date
or one specific region but as the
President himself has said that it's up
to him but if the governors are the ones
that implemented the stay at home orders
and you just said that that health
really is under is under state's
jurisdiction is is this a matter for the
states to decide how they ramped back up
and when I think the best approach is
going to be focusing on the ankle not on
a date and seven criteria for gradually
on safely reopening and then indicating
to a state or a city or a locality that
if they get these things done then this
is how they can reopen and if the
federal government establishes the
principles that are evidence-based for
that based on advice from the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention will
have the highest likelihood of being
able to open as soon and safely as
possible you ran the CDC for years I
have to get your thoughts more on the
w-h-o and China I know you said you
don't want to look back you want to look
forward but in order to really look
forward maybe not in the immediate
future but in the long-term future we we
do need to have a World Health
Organization we can trust
and if diseases are coming out of China
or in this case as one did how concerned
are you or troubled are you about about
what happened with the w-h-o the
ignoring of Taiwan their warnings that
there was human to human transmission
telling us that that this was that you
know that the the evidence wasn't as
severe in mid-january I mean when you
look back right now what is your advice
for China wh o and us moving forward
it's really important that we work with
Holly Rachel and also that we strengthen
wh o that you look at the way that uho
is structured it is limited because of
the structure that it has to live with
them
decisions have to be made with every
single country in the world agreeing on
one key staff are appointed based on
votes from the countries that are around
them their actual authority is extremely
limited so in my view waho has done well
in terms of their guidance documents in
terms of communicating from the time
that it was clear that this was
spreading widely they've been sounding
the alarm
globally they've been open to getting
input and advice I'm sure in any
organizations action even look back and
say you would have done this or that
differently but going forward I think we
have to look more broadly at in terms of
global health what do we as a world need
for w-h-o and other entities to be able
to sound alarms respond to alarms and
prevent the kind of deadly epidemics
that are not only happening now but
inevitably going to happen in the future
what doesn't an organization like w-h-o
then need to have some skepticism toward
communist or authoritarian regimes and
say well we'd love to believe you China
or X Y Z country but but we can't you
know you you guys don't operate with a
level of transparency that you know a
European country does or or a United
States
my first day of medical school the Dean
told us don't believe anything you hear
and only half of what you see and I
think in public health we would be well
advised to take that kind of skepticism
to heart and recognize that things are
not always what they seem in any country
and we need concrete data on the wrong
information and objective assessment of
situations so that we can do the
protection that we need
well dr. Tom Frieden thank you so much
for your time I appreciate it thank you
very much
[Music]
this is leslie marshall with your fox
news commentary coming up this era of
being socially distant staying at home
has affected everyone and every industry
especially one no longer flying i the
airline business has been hit very hard
so hard the two trillion dollar economic
stimulus bill president from a sign
includes up to sixty billion to keep the
industry from being grounded completely
how bad is it in recent days the number
of passengers screened by the TSA is
down ninety six percent from this time
last year many airlines have cut their
service by 80 percent or more fox
business networks Jeff flock saw the
fallout firsthand I am standing outside
a back fence at O'Hare Airport in
Chicago where I see a dozen united
airlines 777 aircraft all stacked up and
parked part of ten thousand planes
worldwide according to the International
Air Transport Association that have been
completely idled as a result of the
corona virus outbreak so with fewer
planes in the sky many of them nearly
empty and with most Americans ordered to
stay home fearful of being near anyone
let alone elbow-to-elbow with a stranger
on a flight the industry is in trouble
oh it's disastrous I mean it suddenly
it's like having a business and there's
no business I mean there's nobody who
wants to use your services Michael Boyd
has been in the industry for decades and
he presides over his own aviation
forecasting and consulting firm Boyd
group International one airline says
they're losing a hundred million dollars
a day so either we get up out of our
caves and start to bring the economy
back even wave goodbye to this airline
industry you said an airline is losing a
hundred million dollars a day which
airline was that that was that was
American Delta said they were losing 60
million so I know and it it's so I mean
this stuff about why why should they fly
this stuff you have to fly everywhere
you flew before why you take a grant
from the government you gotta fly empty
airplanes that's stupid they need to
shut down conserve their cash come back
up bare-bones and try to grow back with
the economy okay so you think the the
entire industry should shut down shut
down and reorganize right now not
carrying anybody why would you fly this
stuff about oh my god you're gonna
you're gonna cut Myrtle Beach off from
the world no or not you know the fact of
the matter is there's nobody at those
gates anyway alright so how how do you
shut down the commercial airline
business well we've got a good jump on
it right now with a couple thousand
planes parked so no you just sit down
and say in 7 days we're gonna come back
it you know instead of having your eight
flights a day from Dallas to Chicago
we're gonna have three and it's gonna be
small airplanes so you you you just
reach structure it now for me to sit
here on the phone from Moose Mountain in
Colorado it's easy for me to say that
it's very hard for Doug Parker at
American Airlines the CEO to make it
happen but we're gonna have to do
something we can't keep operating the
way we are we mentioned earlier the
federal government's financial aid to
the airline's well the details were
ironed out on Tuesday afternoon and
right after that the president said this
agreement will fully support airline
industry workers preserve the vital role
airlines play in our economy and protect
taxpayers our airlines are now in good
shape all the major carriers agreed to
take loans and grants half the funds
will go to keeping up payrolls through
September 30th though there have already
been tens of thousands of workers
furloughed and there's something Michael
boy doesn't like well the problem is its
money to pay employees that's really
great and it's predicated upon you have
to get a waiver not to fly somewhere so
the intent was will pay employees you
can keep flying empty airplanes all
around the country I don't think it's
gonna work at all go into more detail
what you mean by that because I'm not
I'm not exactly sure what it would a
waiver not to fly oh well here's the
deal that the idea is on paper if you
accept these grants and these loans
right you are required to keep flying to
everywhere you flew on March 1 now
whoever dreamed that up is a [ __ ]
because you're telling an airline that
you have to keep flying to places that
have no passengers they still think you
know if you don't if you don't fly to to
Wichita it's gonna die the fact is
there's no passengers in Wichita so
airlines are allowed to go to the
Department of Transportation say I need
waivers to not fly to the following city
so far they've they've applied for about
a hundred and twenty six cities now
we're actually airports not to fly to
there should be more than that but the
fact of the matter is why would you make
an airline fly to places where there's
no passengers and then they don't really
seem to match because the airlines want
the money
yeah well the airline say well airlines
need the money there's no question about
it but the fact is telling the airlines
you could take the money you've got to
keep flying and losing more money
because the money is only for employee
salaries and benefits
it doesn't cover fuel doesn't cover
maintenance cost doesn't cover the
overhead for the airplane doesn't cover
lease cost anything like that so it
covers part of it but not all of it so
you're still I'm you might be losing a
hundred million in a day well now I'm
gonna be lonely be losing sixty big deal
so it's more cost-effective to say no to
the government's money and just shut
down that would be my opinion either
that or you just shut down and readjust
your your system but agree it's a real
deal with the devil to say if I take
your money I have to keep flying to
places where everything is empty because
idiots in Congress think that there's
passengers there let's talk about the
aircraft itself and what you think could
be done to make it better for social
distancing do you have to have every
other row do you have to have every
other seat do you have to have plastic
up between rows what can be done well
any of those things and you brought up a
good point you can't get on an airplane
without being in proximity to somebody I
mean you can't say we're know March
people down six feet six feet six feet
six feet you'll never get the airplane
bored it'd take an hour at least right
and yeah they said well we'll only sit
every other row finally won't make any
money then so and besides that when you
get off the airplane
don't get up the overhead because the
guy in front of you was getting his bag
out we've got to find a way to sanitize
airplanes and sanitize the air is
already sanitized in modern airplanes
but things that get touched so how do we
work that out and how do we make sure
that every time someone gets off the
airplane the airplane is sanitized vac I
think can be done but we have to focus
on doing that rather than just simply
saying well we'll wait till the virus
goes away hey listen
coming back in China right now it never
was cured in China so China's starting
at it all over again so it could come
back again we may be with this so we
either let this kill us physically or
economically or we do something
different let's get a pilot's
perspective now and how to make a plane
safer to be on in this corona nightmare
Rob mark is a commercial pilot and a
blogger at jet wine calm and that's wine
with an H I think it's gonna be very
difficult for the airlines to get going
again
and put people in a small space and not
require something like a mask for some
period of time when you're sitting two
or three inches away from somebody I
don't I don't understand I guess I don't
think anybody really knows how we're
going to cope with that kind of
situation that's it it is actually
rather unique you know us and maybe a
movie house you know when those get back
on how are we going to put people closer
together again but I think it's gonna be
quite a while before we hear a flight
attendant get on the PA and say well
we're expecting a full flight today
that's that's gonna be a ways a ways
away if you have every other row
wherever your other seats how do our
lines make money well see that's that's
the problem you know is that they've
they've kind of made a a business out of
jamming lots of bodies in lots of seats
and but let's let's not feel too badly
for the airlines I mean they've had
they've had a record decade of billions
of dollars in profits and and that was
certainly a turnaround from where it
used to be when you heard that they only
lost X million or a hundred million per
per year but I mean that all started
when they realized they could start
charging us for bags and to pick seats
and to climb on the airplane ahead of
somebody else
and they realized that that was a just a
bonanza for them and and so they've made
a lot of money and honestly too we have
to admit
airlines spent a lot airlines and even
companies like Boeing spent a lot of
money buying their shares back to to
keep those dividends going to their
shareholders and I don't think they were
real worried about about passengers and
now it's a different story and they're
saying oh my gosh you've got to help us
or we're going to go broke I and and we
don't want that either how do you have
workforce not be cut back in the coming
months with hardly any flights we're
talking not just pilots where you're
talking to flight attendants you're
talking about people who do maintenance
you're talking about the baggage crews
how do you do it you don't you're you're
you're basically putting your putting
their salaries on a credit card and and
you're saying that come after Labor Day
those few weeks before the end of
September when these these restrictions
are supposed to wind down that's when
it's going to get really interesting
because they're they're going to be able
to lay people off and I think we're
going to see unless there is some major
nudge to get the the system back going
and I think the airlines certainly will
be pushing hard to get the system back
running as close to normal as possible
because they don't want to lay people
off they really don't and maybe a few of
us
they really don't because they want to
get back to where they were making a lot
of money and I mean let's face it that's
that's capitalism that's how we operate
of course with very few people traveling
and airport stores closed it's affecting
nearly everyone who works there and the
local communities not getting tax
revenues another issue all those planes
sitting idle the longer they don't fly
the longer it will take to get them
ready to it's not like a car where you
say okay let's get 609 on the line here
and we'll take it on the next trip and
you know here are the keys and start it
up and go over there it doesn't work
like that
airplanes need need maintenance when
they've been sitting for a long time and
so you multiply the number of
maintenance technicians
around to get the airplanes going by the
hundreds and hundreds of airplanes that
may need to get going and that alone is
going to be a mess and we were talking
about that just with the the 737 max
issue a few months ago that Boeing right
now yeah when that got back together
they were still going to have to get
those airplanes flying so now we've
we've probably increased the number of
airplanes sitting around tenfold all
over the world but now it is quiet all
the time and and we know inside this
isn't coming back right away
I mean we don't know where the end date
is thank you to rob mark for his insight
and his last thought is something people
questioned nearly 20 years ago when
airlines were grounded after the
hijacked planes were used in the 9/11
terror attacks back to Michael Boyd who
says this coronavirus threat is not the
same everything is different at 9/11 you
know it was fear of somebody blowing up
your airplanes here it's a very real
situation where you know if you bump
into somebody at the Rose in the food
counter at the grocery store you're
gonna get a disease let alone on an
airplane so right now the difference is
then we had demand here we have no
demand the demand has been evaporated
well I did fly in late September 2001
and I went to San Francisco from Boston
and there were about seven people on the
plane so there were people fearful at
the time of getting on an airplane just
like we have now how long did that come
back in 2001 where people were like okay
all I think I'm good with this it took a
couple years to get back to that demand
a bigger hit was the 2008 recession I
mean you know even today we're flying
fewer airplanes now than we were in 2007
so I mean if there are hits that hit but
they're not as fundamental as telling
people you have to stay at home you
can't go to the airport even if you want
to do and if you go to the airport you
might get a dread disease that might
give you a stomachache or might kill you
Michael Boyd thank you very much for
joining us my pleasure sir you have a
good day you too thanks Michael much
appreciated thank you
all right bye-bye all right take care
[Music]
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
to campaign with bread pair with updates
from reporters on the trail and in
studio experts Bret keeps you informed
on the 2020 race go to Fox News podcast
comm and download the campaign with Bret
Baier now Rayden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your fox news
commentary what's on your mind
senator bernie sanders acted in the best
interest of the democratic party and the
nation when he dropped out of the race
for the Democratic presidential
nomination but now he's gone one step
further in acting in the best interest
of the Democratic Party in the nation by
endorsing former Vice President Joe
Biden for Democratic nominee to run
against Donald Trump in the upcoming
election in November 2020 in addition
former President Barack Obama has also
weighed in and added his endorsement of
the former vice president for that
Democratic presidential nomination so
now that Joe Biden is the presumptive
Democratic presidential nominee what
should he do going forward to make
Donald Trump a one-term president one be
more visible Biden is doing weekly
podcast and posting to those online and
giving media interviews but his team
needs to be more aggressively seeking
out as many media interviews as possible
to keep him in the news so he doesn't
become an invisible man he needs to hold
regular news conferences to compete with
Trump's daily White House press
briefings he also should partner with
Sanders unfortunately Sanders said he
was going to remain on the primary
ballots to get convention delegate
support in order to influence the
Democratic Party platform in direction
but Biden needs to reach out to Bernie
and to the greatest extent to his
supporters to form a team and to end
their rivalry the endorsement by Sanders
of Biden is the first step in the right
direction to do that now Trump has
appealed to the supporters of Sanders
however for their votes
Biden needs more than just Sanders
endorsement he needs Sanders to explain
to
his supporters the Bernie or bust folks
those diehard supporters that while
Sanders and Biden have their differences
those differences are minor compared
with the enormous differences between
Sanders and Donald Trump something else
Baida needs to do is to unify Democrats
and appeal to swing voters he needs to
do more than build an alliance with
Bernie Sanders the former vice president
needs to appeal to all Democratic
factions and also to independents and
two Republicans who dislike Trump for
any number of reasons capturing a good
chunk of these swing voters is crucial
to put Biden in the White House Biden is
already committed to selecting a woman
as his vice presidential running mate
that's a smart move he needs to give
serious consideration to picking a
minority woman to boost his support
among minority voters although he
already enjoys far more minority support
than Trump Biden also needs to remind
voters what's at stake in the election
if Trump stays in office and gets to
appoint one or more Supreme Court
justices the High Court could turn back
the clock on many progressive victories
involving abortion rights health care
civil rights immigrant rights and other
issues in addition Trump has shown he is
committed to cutting taxes for the
richest Americans and cutting programs
to help the poorest Americans the middle
class and minorities Biden needs to get
millions of more voters to understand
that voting for him is in their own
self-interest we face a strange election
campaign in the months ahead
limited for as long as the coronavirus
limits gatherings and dominates the news
but the bottom line is that now that
Bernie Sanders has withdrawn from the
race and supported Joe Biden by
endorsing him for president it allows
the former vice president to focus now
on Trump instead of on his rivals and
that's good news for everyone who wants
to see a Democrat in the White House in
2021
I'm Leslie Marshall
you've been listening to the Box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes